[Musik]
der gipfel götz bei kunden mitten in der
schweiz
[Musik]
1200 höhenmeter zwei künstler ein berg
und ein bett unter freiem himmel steht
ein hotelzimmer das ganz ohne dach und
wände aus kommt das null stern hotel ein
konzept der künstler zwillinge frank und
patrik riklin das interessant dass viele
leute nicht mehr wissen was ist jetzt
groß dieses tourismus ist innovation
dass ich das sparen daran dass wir die
leute auch ein bisschen verunsichert
keine wand tapete sondern die grandiose
kulisse rund ums bett zieht menschen aus
der ganzen welt an
wir haben dieses bett inszeniert gebaut
und dann eröffnet und ab dem moment was
eigentlich voll gebucht
wegen der david dieser umdrehungen
bedeutet ja nicht verzicht auf luxus
sondern eben dass er fan eines anderen
neuen luxus hier im appenzellerland
hatte ein bauer köbi dietrich bisher
wenig mit kunst zu tun
jetzt ist er mittendrin als empfangschef
und butler jeden abend nach dem kühe
melken wird der alm wird teil des
kunstprojektes die idee war wie kann man
ein konzept das natürlich kunst ist ins
leben rufen und die spieler die player
also die menschen die um dieses
kunstwerk leben teil davon werden
ohne ihn wäre das viel zu klassisch also
er springt eigentlich oder hüpft oder
schlüpft eigentlich in dieses kunstwerk
hinein also wie immer nichts als
künstler spricht ist nun stemweder im
bild das aber lebt ein einsamer ein
bauer der hier im sommer mit frau
kindern und kühn lebt bekommt
urplötzlich jeden tag neuen besuch und
er genießt es erstaunlicherweise so tag
macht ähnlich mit dem helikopter und die
hat er die wiese und video machen also
ich richtig sexy und zieht neue york
times ist glücklich und ich hatte aber
nicht so guten auch rund 260 euro kostet
die freiluft übernachtung mit bergblick
und frühstück die neuen gäste kommen die
beiden freunde leben in genf und haben
eine kurzfristig frei werdenden acht
ergattern können
und sie sind die ersten gäste die die
künstler hier persönlich treffen
[Musik]
das ist die beste idee auf der ganzen
welt das ist toll und so fühlen sich die
beiden schnell heimisch schon schwebt
rafah ältermann stone über ihnen um das
alte feeling festzuhalten
ich war es der die gesagt hat wir sollen
hierher kommen
wer kann schon so einschlafen inmitten
der schönsten tage der welt mit einem
solchen sonnenuntergang
ich kann das noch nicht realisieren ich
denke ich brauche ein wenig zeit es ist
unwirklich das fernsehprogramm
wetterprognose witze oder musik analog
von mensch zu mensch
[Musik]
künstlerische kritik am digitalisierungs
war der einzige star hier ist der gast
das ist die null stern philosophie wenn
man sieht wie die leute dann reagieren
wie sie diesem kunstwerk daneben sich
auch bewegen und begeistert sind dann
begeistert dass er selber aus als wir
merken dann dass dieses konzept lebt
[Musik]
am morgen kommt der regen
die gäste müssen in die ersatzunterkunft
umziehen in die hütte von bauer köbi
dietrich zum frühstück gibt es eier
milch und schinken vom hof auch alles
andere kommt aus der region
es ist ein traum und dann wird man
morgens wach und es ist kein traum
eine erfahrung ich habe unglaublich gut
geschlafen das bett war super bequem
es war angenehm es gab ein paar mücken
aber man gewöhnt sich dran
kommerzielle angebote für ihr konzept
sogar einen millionendeal haben die
künstler abgelehnt wie es weitergeht mit
dem null stern hotel lassen sie offen